all right
okok do we have in the round so let's
check it out and we got empty the boss
on gameplay and let's check it out Wow
your star looks absolutely fantastic top
what platforms are we looking for for
this game right now at the moment we are
developing on PC okay but of course we
will consider all the major content
afterwards - well one thing left out is
the art style and the light sourcing
looks really fantastic especially
animations which is sweeping so what
engine are we using or utilizing is this
unity is it son
again basic premise yes this is like
escape from the game now with enemies
like that cone of vision right now
[Music]
what's very cool two of the little
subtle animations that the character
does when he's up against the wall be
kind of high he touches things and stuff
like that to really give off that
impression of stealth which is a very
cool
[Music]
the best era perfect term forever being
English over there for example so he can
utilize that like for example again
let's let's get back into story again oh
I want to see if that month didn't catch
him that Hmong has some serious issues
Miguel focus now again let's talk about
like level design is it is it more like
you know seamless levels going like
basic structure with level or not or
open-world like how the level design we
come to like a go Bend it's controlled
kind of town then we have the typical
Western stuff here without the Train
[Music]
[Music]
was it going on clearly he has a
fixation with that now what about like
any storm I guess for our story
mechanics is any type of cinematics as
far as in the game as far as telling we
just want to explain more of the story
itself yes we do have a few cinematics
ok not too many or if they're Mia
because smaller units doing that and
they are like we actually we skip the
intro we can maybe have a look at it
later on gotcha and this is explains the
story we won't use voice okay yeah we
will just explain it by explaining
senior it won't be text to read and no
voices to hear just like you
[Music]
how long has been in development for you
guys with the project I think this would
be a perfect especially with you know
you have no official announcements to
make
I know it's a big thing in the gaming
community right now war is game
streaming is but it wouldn't be a
platform you guys would consider I mean
we've seen the show does it matter what
platform you're on good point basically
good point
I would love to be to go from THQ and
depending it's best always to be on any
platform that there is to make the
players play this is oh boy I love the
double
expecting different results
yeah you're not gonna get away from this
guy
she looks away now you can run the bet
there you go there you go alright now
see the key is down here this is where
things get a little complicated
yep because we got this whole rotation
going on oh yeah I think we're we're
done here
so again for Kinect pronunciation ok
coming to all platforms first PC fir and
when are we targeting possible window
for early next year so early 2020 yes
all right you all ready here for a fan
LG ho you got some good stuff mechanics
some fun monastery play it's for you
heard of here first Lords of gaming a
little podcast